[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous leurs du 7-8 journal sur
tv 60,18 l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale et régionale tout de suite les
titres de ce jeudi et 5 juillet c'est
l'agencé technique départementale
ingénierie apporte aux communes une
assistance à maîtrise d'ouvragé
notamment dans la préservation du
patrimoine local
dans cette édition exemple année zèle et
bazoches sur guyonne ou une église du
12e siècle va pouvoir être restaurée
elle des attaques en occitanie dans les
hautes france est maintenant dans le
département depuis quelques mois des
boucheries sont victimes de dégradations
par des militants antispécistes est
dernière action en date à jouy en josas
en début de semaine pour en parler en
plateau et jean-raymond dumas est notre
invité président du syndicat de la
boucherie charcuterie d'île de france
enfin quelques jours des vacances d'été
nous irons prendre la température à
thoiry le parc zoologique s'apprête à
accueillir ses visiteurs et les animaux
sont à choyer en cette période de
grandes chaleurs
elle nous recevons également dans cette
édition à thérèse mallet maire adjointe
à magny les hameaux magny les hameaux
qui organise une nouvelle fois à partir
de la semaine prochaine une nouvelle
édition de remets tes tongs c'est à
suivre dans ce journal est la visite de
jean-louis borloo dans les yvelines à
chanteloup-les-vignes l'ancien ministre
assistait à la signature d'une
convention départementale un plan
d'amore ce pour la rénovation urbaine de
plusieurs quartiers emblématiques du
territoire dont celui du val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie et jean louis borloo
hauteur tout récemment du rapport vivre
ensemble vivre en grand pour une
réconciliation nationale qui préconisait
la mise en place d'un grand plan pour
les banlieues est des recommandations
finalement non retenu par le président
de la république
emmanuel macron c'est une agence unique
en ile-de-france ingénierie a pour
objectif d'apporter son aide et
expertise aux petites communes rurales
des yvelines depuis sa création en 2014
dans le département trois cent quarante
projets ont été soutenus à des dossiers
dans les domaines du bâtiment de la
voirie et de l'urbanisme et maintenant
du patrimoine exemple dans deux communes
avec ce reportage de nickel et demi
d'euros et carla vigeant il est
symptomatique de voir
lièrement des tuiles des bouts de tuiles
tombées comme ce beau morceau là des
murs qui tombent en ruine une végétation
envahissante la petite commune de
bazoches sur guyonne ne peut assumer le
coût de l'entretien de cette église
romane du 12e siècle pour l'aider la
commune de 600 habitants a fait appel à
l'agencé ingénierie créé par le
département
cette dernière va l'aider à hauteur de
6000 euros par an et un carnet
d'entretien qui a été décidé par l'agent
orange et néry et qui est un carnet
d'entretien qui va nous permettre de
mettre en oeuvre les petites opérations
d'entretien extérieur de l'édifice
lagence ingéniérie va également
conseillé la mairie dans ses choix
d'artisans là on a vraiment besoin de
faire un décapage complet de la porte
d'un traitement du bois et on ne peut
pas évidemment prendre n'importe quel
artisan pour faire ce travail là puisque
l'église est inscrite à l'inventaire
supplémentaire des monuments historiques
et donc comprendre à un homme de l'art
pas tenté pour faire ce genre de travaux
à 21 kilomètres de là année zélande
village de 1100 habitants c'est un
centre de loisirs de 44 enfants qui a
bénéficié du soutien d'ingénierie en
2017 de la conception de l'aménagement à
la réalisation
la partie administrative la partie
financière passat à un soutien très très
très important au total ingénierie a
aidé à monter plus de 340 projet depuis
sa création 2014 dans le secteur du
bâtiment de l'urbanisme et de la voirie
l' agence technique est même devenu
indispensable selon son président
quand vous prenez un budget
d'investissement d'une petite commune
c'est sur l'ensemble de 100000 euros et
le moindre projet c'est 300 400 mille
euros donc ils peuvent pas des dizaines
de nouveaux projets sont déjà à l'étude
pour la fin de l'année au total le
budget d'ingéniérie avoisine les 800
mille euros autres restaurations à
voisins le bretonneux la police
municipale bénéficier désormais d'un
commissariat rénover le bâtiment
réhabilité situé à proximité de la
mairie a été inauguré ce jeudi matin le
chantier a concerné l'extérieur et
l'intérieur de la structure et des
vestiaires ont notamment été ajoutées
coût total 160 mille euros environ des
travaux de sécurisation est devenu
nécessaire écouter ses propos au micro
de patrick jacques de dixmude
il ya quelques années nous étions rendus
compte que
ce bâtiment avait besoin d'une
réhabilitation importante tant
intérieurement qu'extérieurement pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que il
est un peu vétuste mais ensuite parce
que il reprit avait pas forcément toutes
les conditions de sécurité pour la
police municipale conditions d'accueil
de personnel pmr par exemple de
personnes permet donc on a décidé en
2014 de lancer un projet de
réhabilitation alors dans un premier
temps plutôt léger et puis au fur et à
mesure de nos avancées dans le projet on
s'est rendu compte que il fallait un
projet un petit peu plus important est
la police municipale de
voisins-le-bretonneux compte aujourd'hui
quatre agents et 1 1 as vp chargé de
surveiller la voie publique deux agents
supplémentaires seront recrutés
prochainement et les gendarmes eux
sensibilise en ce moment les usagers des
routes yvelinoise depuis le 1er juillet
la vitesse sur certains axes
départementaux est passé de 90 à 80
km/heure une nouveauté qu'il faut
présenter aux automobilistes avec
pédagogie au bord des routes et dans les
lieux publics
patrick jacques de dixmude et mélanie
poker
et je me permets de vous donner un petit
d'ailleurs concernant le fameux 80 km
heure cet après-midi la padawan les deux
perdent deux points
les contrevenants sont sensibilisés les
gendarmes de la sécurité routière
contrôle sur la d 91 proche de la route
des dix sept tournant je suis très
agréablement surpris qu aujourd'hui la
gendarmerie la police fasse de la
prévention et je trouvais que ça avait
disparu ces derniers temps donc voilà
c'est très positif je pense et on est
plus sensible à partir du moment c'est
de la prévention pas de la répression de
faire de la prévention je trouve ça une
bonne chose par contre le 80 je suis
vraiment pas pour sept militaires sont
mobilisés en deux équipes ils contrôlent
la vitesse et les flux en vallée de
chevreuse
notre mission c'est de faire appliquer
le code de la route à la health émission
assez simple mais il ya plein de façons
de le faire
dans le cas de cette mesure qui se fait
en période estivale à partir du dimanche
il est nécessaire d'accompagner cette
mesure donc des excès de vitesse qui
sont minimes qui sont mineurs si le
contrôle se passe de manière positive
avec la personne qui sont en infraction
on peut engager un dialogue et une
discussion pédagogie tôt mardi 4 juillet
la nouvelle limitation est en place la
sensibilisation continue même hangar il
faut laisser le temps de voir quels
seront les effets est ce que on parlait
tout de suite dire non ça sert à rien si
on regarde bien ce qui a fait la
prévention routière depuis le début elle
a imposé le port du casque on a dit que
ça servait à rien imposer la ceinture de
sécurité à l'avant on a dit ça sert à
rien la ceinture de sécurité à l'arrière
m'a dit que ça servait à rien chaque
phase a eu un impact quand même sur
london d'emploi près de contrôle indique
que c'est bon le dépistage à fonctionner
correctement et là en fait la barre du
tsoup vous allez que c'est positif a
qu'à la mise
c'est bien c'est au lieu de les voir
tout le temps faire des infractions il
nous explique un petit peu c'est je
pense que c'est c'est l'ordre des choses
avant de donner des instructions nous
expliquer comment ça fonctionne le
gouvernement espère sauver 400 vies par
an avec cette mesure dans les yvelines
58 radars sont présents deux sont
concernés par la mesure du 80 km heure
là des boucheries vandalisée à plusieurs
reprises en france en début de semaine
un établissement a été pris pour cible à
jouy en josas dans les yvelines la
vitrine brisée un tag antispécistes
inscrits sur la devanture qui traduisent
le climat actuel de tensions autour de
la profession a débouché des bouchers
charcutiers pardon pour en parler en
plateau avec moi jean raymond dumas
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le président
du syndicat des bouchers charcutiers
d'île de france ça regroupe trois
départements les yvelines l'essonne et
le val d'oise avant de commencer cet
entretien une définition
d'abord les antispécistes sont des
militants de la cause animale il refuse
la notion d'espacé et revendiquent les
mêmes droits pour les animaux que pour
l'être humain
il condamne il condamne donc les mises à
mort d'animaux une boucherie ciblées à
jouy en josas genre et monde humain
c'est s'en prendre à l'ensemble de la
profession
oui s'il s'en prendre à l'ensemble de la
position 1 profession puisque ça fait
comme des mois que ça dure ça déjà on a
commencé par le nord l'occitanie
on a eu en maine et loire on a eu un
bretagne un peu paris et moi dans les
yvelines jusqu'à présent j'avais été
épargnés s'ils arrivent chez nous donc
on a une peur vie pour mes collègues
d'autant plus que c'est c'est de la
lâcheté puisque venir la nuit sa cage
est une façade
de boucherie c'est pas acceptable et
c'est s'attaquer à des gens qui font
simplement leur métier j'essaie des
garçons enfin td des hommes et des
femmes qu'il faut d un métier qu'ils
aiment
la revendication de ces gens là on la
respecte mais on doit pas s'attaquer à
casser du matériel et s'attaquer dès des
humains comme ils le font comme ils le
font aujourd'hui en sachant qu'il faut
le préciser quand les deux mouvement
antispéciste principaux qui sont l214 et
269 libération un animal non ont indiqué
ne pas avoir dirigé cette action contre
cette boucherie à jouy en josas vous le
disiez jean-raymond dumas plusieurs
attaques en france la dernière à jouy en
josas
il ya aussi un message qui a été publié
il ya quelques mois sur les réseaux
sociaux au moment de l'attentât de
trèbes qui avait visé donc un magasin
super u un message injurieux à
l'encontre du boucher qui avait été tué
pendant l attente de la femme avait fait
passer ce message facebook
hélas la ds c'est vraiment pas
acceptable se souhaiter la fin c'était
valider la mort d'un boucher je crois
que le gouvernement a fait tout ce qu'il
fallait
elle était jugée retrouver jugé
et effectivement condamné c'est un
climat de tension que vous ressentez
depuis plusieurs semaines puis deux puis
est ce qu on a surtout peur c'est que ça
prenne des amplitudes de beaucoup plus
importante est que chez nos confrères
des nouvelles de versailles que ça
finisse en drame ce genre de situation
c'est ce que j'ai pas c'est que nous on
ne veut pas la bagarre on veut être au
calme
on respecte ces gens là mais ce que j'ai
peur c'est que demain
malheureusement un de ces individus se
fasse prendre part à nos confrères ou
collègues et que malheureusement ça
termine mal parce que je pense que quand
ils vont tomber d'un emad à nos
confrères on est on est débouchée je
veux dire qu'on n'est pas des gars qui
se l'est non plus faire on veut pas ça
on ne veut pas mais on avertit tout à
pau enfin ces gens on les avertit de
faire très attention justement pour
avertir vous avez été reçu au ministère
de l'intérieur les représentants
nationaux de votre syndicat suite à ces
attaques vous demandez quoi aujourd'hui
et bien que le gouvernement met vraiment
en place tout ce qu'il faut pour arrêter
cette émeute
ces gens par le biais et que ça soit pas
nous qui faisons notre justice parce que
c'est pas à nous de la faire il ya une
justice qui a des gendarmes il a tout ce
qu'il faut et c'est ce qu'on leur
demande donc je crois qu'on a été écouté
il ya des choses qui est en train de se
mettre en place
là ils nous ont écoutés je pense que le
travail ça va se faire petit à petit on
a confiance en nous vous avez été reçu
par le ministère de l'intérieur si vous
êtes satisfait de cette rencontre fait
justement leur parlons aussi de la
profession de boucher plus généralement
c'est l'occasion d'en parler dans ce
journal est ce que c'est une profession
dans les yvelines en ile-de-france qui
se porte bien bien sûr les boucheries
qui sont
installé on a de belles affaires les
affaires marchent bien le consommateur
bien chez son boucher pour avoir de la
qualité de la qualité des humains en
face à eux
et bien sûr que le consommateur est prêt
et prix continuent à nous faire
travailler quoi il ya vous le dites une
profession de qualité une profession
d'excellence est ce que c'est un métier
qui est dénigré aujourd'hui à votre avis
non il est pas dénigrer et il est sain
métis à savoir fait on a un savoir faire
et tout le monde peut pas le faire et
puis le consommateur le réclament
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça qu'on ne doit
pas imposer le ces gens ne doivent pas
imposer de ne plus manger de viande
c'est au consommateur de décider et on
est libre de faim le consommateur libre
de manger ce qui peut aussi y en a qui
veulent manger que de la carac la
carotte ou de la salade
c'est leur droit ils vont droit parlait
pas contre leurs idées mais c'est pas d
imposer aux autres voilà vous réclamez
plusieurs études montrent que la
consommation de viande baisse d'année en
année ce que ça se ressent sur votre
clientèle
il faut être franc aujourd'hui le
consommateur branche moins de viande
en revanche y mange de la viande de
qualité d'où il vient chez son artisan
et ça on en est conscient et puis moi
même qui est bouché depuis 35 ans je
mange moins de 10 ans on la mange
différemment mais on en mange moi mais
ça se comprend ça se comprend il ya un
problème là dessus ça nous empêche pas
de devis et puis aujourd'hui puisqu'on
je suis mieux celle en tête je me
permets de dire que chez nous on
embauche on attend des jeunes pour venir
travailler que ça suscite des vocations
est ce que les jeunes générations sont
intéressés par ce que nous et nos écoles
sont pleines laisser façon plein et
aujourd'hui à boucher sur deux sur trois
réclament un employé qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire aujourd'hui pour devenir
boucher quelles sont les formations
possibles et bien de deux ans de cap21
ses api et après on peut générer sur
deux à bp sur un an deux ans trois ans
pour avoir pour permettre de s'installer
et connaître toutes là toute la filière
viande
mais à la place il ya la place donc
aujourd'hui je dis venez nous voir les
les fédérations les organismes
professionnels sont là pour vous
accueillir les céphalées écoles et venez
nous rejoindre il ya ahmeti assurez vous
serez jamais au chômage c'est le message
est passé merci jean rémi dumas d'avoir
été avec nous merci beaucoup mais je
rappelle que vous êtes le président du
syndicat de la boucherie charcuterie en
ile-de-france qui regroupe notamment le
département des yvelines
vous êtes à la recherche d'une formation
dans le secteur du numérique
saint quentin en yvelines organise lundi
9 juillet à partir de 14h30 une après
midi d'information
c'est pour découvrir les formations
labellisées école du numérique le
numérique un secteur en tension sur
notre territoire puisque en un an et dix
mille offres d'emploi ont été recensés
mais les candidats restent peu nombreux
car pas assez formés dès le mois
d'octobre 13 formations est liée à la
sécurité de l'information à la
programmation ou encore au marketing
digital seront accessibles à à saint
quentin en yvelines
elles sont les invités de l'elysée
demain vendredi 9 footballeuses de
l'étoile sportive de trappes vont
assister à france uruguay au palais
présidentiel
retransmission du quart de finale de la
coupe du monde en compagnie d' emmanuel
macron le club trappistes fait partie de
la délégation officielle de la ligue de
paris de football conviés par le chef de
l'état a pour l'occasion
les français ne sont pas très
accueillant les parisiens peu souriant
ce sont quelques-unes des critiques que
peuvent nous adresser parfois les
touristes étrangers quand ils viennent
en france c'est pour contrer ce genre
d'idées reçues que la région a lancé il
ya deux ans les volontaires du tourisme
plusieurs centaines de jeunes sont
positionnés pour guider les visiteurs
répondre à leurs questions ou tout
simplement leur adresser un sourire est
la nouvelle saison de ces volontaires du
tourisme été lancée en début de semaine
à paris patrick jacques de dixmude et
nicolas kirillovitch
à paris ou dans sa région il est
impossible de les rater quand ils se
déploient les gilets violets ce sont
leurs surnoms il s'agit en fait des
volontaires du tourisme ils sont 600
déployés cet été en ile de france
leur mission est guidé et accueillir les
touristes étrangers à proximité des
lieux emblématiques de la région
ils sont là pour accueillir pour
souhaiter la bienvenue aux visiteurs
quels qu'ils soient
transilien européens et mondiaux et de
manière à ce que les gens se sentent un
peu moins seul depuis son lancement en
décembre 2016 l'opération des
volontaires du tourisme a profité à plus
de 1500 jeunes pour la plupart des
étudiants en tourisme qui tirent profit
de l'affluence des vacances pour
accumuler une précieuse expérience
professionnelle c'est un secteur que
j'ai tout j'ai aimé et ça fait partie
ont fait de mal de ma formation plus que
je suis en école de commerce dont je
pense que c'est une belle opportunité
représente la ville de paris donc
franchement c'est plutôt une
responsabilité
après une année 2010 est record pour le
secteur touristique les professionnels
espèrent un crue similaire cette année
pour amplifier son soutien la région
lancera également à la rentrée un pass
spécial où pourront s'accumuler offre
pour les transports et visites pour les
sites franciliens
nous voulons avoir le maximum de
partenaires sur se passe de façon à
éviter de devoir transporter sa carte
bleue du liquide sur soi
ce qui évidemment est source de
pickpockets d'insécurité donc impasse
très simple très rapide pour les
transports pour les musées l'an passé 48
millions de touristes ont visité l'île
de france l'année 2018 pourrait pâtir
des mouvements sociaux s'il se prolonge
tout l'été pour fêter le début des
vacances d'été un rendez vous
traditionnel revient à magny les hameaux
remets tes tongs se tient du 9 au 14
juillet une semaine d'animations qui se
déroule à l'esplanade
gérard philipe pour en parler thérèse
mallem bons soirs comme ça vous êtes la
6e maire adjointe de la commune en
charge de la communication et de la
démocratie locale alors remettez tongs
c'est un rendez-vous qui revient
chaque année puisque c'est la neuvième
édition pourquoi proposer cet événement
à magny-les-hameaux
parce que c'est un événement qui est
très attendu par les mamies quoi
beaucoup d'activités pour les jeunes
c'est souvent la semaine où il qu'ils
attendent avant de partir en vacances ou
pendant leurs vacances et c'est
tellement de choses qui est offerte par
la municipalité gratuitement justement
il ya des animations pendant l'été qui
seront organisées dans les autres
communes pendant les vacances la de le
faire juste avant on va dire au tout
début des vacances d'été c'est
finalement de fêter cet été qui a rien
donc vous terminez l'école âgé c'est
vrai qu'on est à la fin de la semaine
qui se termine donc vendredi c'est la
fin de l'école dès lundi à partir de 14
heures commencera l'événement rené tu es
tout donc pour eux ces voix là on
enchaîne tout de suite avec des
activités et beaucoup de joie pour eux
parce qu'ils ont énormément d'activités
qui leur sont proposés alors rendez vous
appréciez vous le disais ce que beaucoup
de gens il participe chaque année à oui
on compte approximativement 400
personnes par jour en tout âge confondu
bien entendu il faut savoir que les
grands parents souvent gardent leurs
petits enfants et pour eux c'est une
aubaine quoi de pouvoir leur permettre
aux enfants d'avoir des activités parce
qu'il faut les occuper les petits
donc c'est vrai que les activités sont
proposées à partir de 1 an risque à
l'âge que vous voulez c'est très large
les objectifs qu'on peut dire c'est
favoriser peut-être le lien social entre
les manier quoi plus ça c'est un point
très fort des rencontres exactement
sensibiliser sont pas mal de domaines et
puis si c'était les rencontres discuter
partager rire s'amuser et enfin et si je
pense que cette année ça va être comme
quelque chose de très fort et c'est une
semaine qui a rendu possible quand on
regarde la liste des partenaires il ya
de nombreux partenaires des associations
de la ville notamment des partenaires
qui rend possible finalement là aussi
d'un événement fiq
alors en plus mon bas le programme je
vais pas vous le détailler parce qu'il
est tellement long et large mais bon
c'est vrai qu'il va y avoir quand même
quelque chose de très important donc le
mercredi à l'aide d'une piste de roller
d'accord oui les enfants nathalie son
devront amener leurs rollers et venir
s'amuser tout l'après midi et il faut
savoir que vous m'avez pas posé la
question je pense que ça peut décaler
elle allait venir exactement parce que
cette année il ya une thématique on va
dire faire autour de remettez ton on
peut d'ailleurs retrouver le programme
complet sur le site internet de magny
les hameaux
si une thématique dédié au golf on est à
quelques mois de la ryder cup la plus
compétition de golf qui va débarquer en
septembre à saint quentin en yvelines
très content mais alors donc le fil
conducteur s'arrête le swing donc ils
sont ils ont produire du golfe en tongs
va pour essayer
on peut essayer mais effectivement donc
tout au long de cette semaine il va y
avoir une initiation puisqu'en même
temps le village ryder cup se déplace à
magny les hameaux donc un jour de la
semaine pour initier pour expliquer un
peu ski et le golf au jeune monica et
puis il va y avoir donc le dé tout et
des activités autour du swing qui est
aussi la danse donc comment allier ma le
golfe et puis la nuit semant la danse on
imagine l'idée aussi c'est de faire
connaître le golfe on connaît davantage
d'autres sports commencer la coupe du
monde de football c'est aussi peut-être
de faire connaître d'ouvrir lémanique ou
à d'autres sports comme le golf c'est
une histoire de démocratiser aussi ce
sport qui est quand même assez est
l'équipe qui est quand même un beau
sport et puis bon c'est vrai qu'on ne
riez pas il n'ya pas spontanément faire
du gauche donc peut-être que c'était
l'envié à certains jeunes ou moins
jeunes pas de un jour vouloir s'inscrire
et puis être un talent futurs talents
vous disiez un programme varié pour tous
les âges ce rtt remets tes tongs
ce n'est pas que du golfe une multitude
d'animations du 9 au 14 juillet à
l'esplanade gérard philipe du sport du
spectacle de rue des ateliers
artistiques et emmanuel c'est ça qu'il
faut retenir on va pas détailler le
programme et qui est une multitude
d'activités sur différents secteurs
moi j'ai pris un peu comme comme vous
voulez si je me suis jetée vrai que avec
ses activités il a quand même des grands
thèmes qui ressorte c'est on peut on
s'éveille
on crée on apprend on joue on bouge on
se promène on se détend on se régale on
rêve on danse et on rit pas de mieux
pendant une semaine et donc ça pendant
une semaine et on peut le dire aussi ce
cette semaine se terminera le 14 juillet
jour de fête nationale et là il y aura
aussi une
grande est proposée une surprise mais
c'est un événement fort de la semaine
rtt c'est le banquet républicain
donc c'est vrai nous ça fait deux ans
qu'on a opté pour ne plus tirer le feu
d'artifice qui se fait aux alentours
dont les habitants peuvent le pot en
profite et ailleurs et nous on a opté
pour faire un grand pique nique
républicain où on propose aux manies pas
de ramener un dessert de partager la
table avec tous les habitants qui
veulent bien se joindre à cet événement
et puis en plus de terminer par un
défilé puisqu'il y aura le défilé des
enfants qui seront déguisés avec le
costume qu'ils ont créés pendant toute
la semaine
d'accord allez du recyclage faut le
préciser et puis ensuite pouvoir danser
sur les thèmes du swing c'est ça ça va
se terminer par un grand bal
exactement pour participer à ces
animations seront directement sur place
il faut s'inscrire à la petite
inscription par terre parce que sinon il
ya des choses qui risque d'être vite
remplie et y en a plus de place mais oui
vous pouvez venir en début de matinée
pour enfin en début d'activité pour vous
inscrire aux activités choisies
il nous reste une minute environ qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour cette
neuvième édition de remettre et 11h jeu
j'ai appris qu'ils allaient faire une
belle météo donc pas de problème au
niveau du temps on aura pas de pluie
comme l'année dernière que ça plaise que
l'émail quoi ça très heureux
je sois encore une réussite et puis
qu'on puisse continuer l'année prochaine
qu'on est tout ce qu'il faut pour y
arriver
merci à thérèse mallem d'avoir être
sixièmes maire-adjointe de magny les
hameaux et pour retrouvez tout le
programme de remets tes tongs rendez
vous sur le site internet de la commune
enfin avec les vacances qui approchent
les sites touristiques du département se
prépare au parc zoologique de thoiry
personnel est pensionnaire s'apprête à
accueillir les visiteurs et avec la
chaleur de ces derniers jours
les animaux sont à bichonner pour
l'occasion reportage de camille lambert
et tutti nirhy lanto il ne faut pas
longtemps à tana et sa famille pour
reconnaître l'appel de mathieu avec les
fortes chaleurs les 18 maki catta du
parc de thoiry endroit un repas un peu
spécial pas tous les jours puisque il
faut que ça reste exceptionnel pour que
ce soit un vrai enrichissement
on va leur donner de temps à autre des
petits glaçons des petits glaçons
composé de fruits et de nectar de fruits
qu'on va préparer à l'avance pour un
petit peu les amuser pendant l'été et
les rafraîchir ouvert depuis l'an
dernier le lémur trek plonge le visiteur
dans l'enclos des débuts rien une
immersion sur certaines conditions
malgré leur accueil sympathique
interdiction de les toucher
si on les touche en fait ils risquent de
perdre leur identité c'est des animaux
qui communique beaucoup avec les odeurs
et en gros si dans une journée il ya 200
personnes qui leur font une petite
gratouille bas à la fin la journée le
lémurien il va avoir perdu son identité
olfactive est en fait il va stresser il
peut être si exclu du groupe
donc faut éviter cela à tout prix non
loin de madagascar direction l'australie
avec les nouveautés du parc cette année
un circuit parmi les kangourous et une
volière où cohabitent six espèces
d'oiseaux dont les loriquets arc en ciel
bien habitué aux visiteurs depuis avril
ils sont assez proches des visiteurs et
on fait avec eux chaque jour pendant
l'été de nourrissage on va leur proposer
de nourrir les petits loriquets donc
c'est les petits gobelets avec du nectar
et les visiteurs peuvent avoir un
oreiller qui leur montrent sur la main
une visite au plus proche des animaux
surtout des plus gourmands c'est la fin
de ce journal l'édition ainsi que ces
reportages sont à retrouver sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 dans quelques minutes un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat nicolas
kirillovitch et ses invités parleront du
congrès convoqué par emmanuel macron ce
lundi à versailles très bonne soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]